better repair we're we're the rudder a
pair we're working on this rudder that's
been damaged in the bottom of ship yeah
they ran aground off the coast of Brazil
and they towed it about a thousand
nautical miles to course out because
there's a port there and they're in
courser we're trying to repair this
rudder on the bottom of the ship without
taking the ship out of the water which
is a real challenge and normally put
that ship and drydock to do this work
but the ship's full of iron ore on its
way to China it's worth a lot of money
they don't want to unload it they want
to get done fast
so we're trying to work underwater to
cut this 50 ton rudder off get it get it
floated up to the surface and there's a
whole system of welding and pad eyes and
putting in the chain falls and trying to
slowly lower it out but I ran into a lot
of obstacles that was so mangled once we
did our first inspected I have the whole
rudder was so mango from hitting the
bottom was just completely bent up but
we got down there we're trying to use
ultra thermic gouging to alter thermic
rods to try to cut out big sections of
Steel we tried to do several different
tricks to internal busted loose
ultimately we had to bring in a diamond
wire saw and cut the whole thing off
I want to give away too much of the
story but we do eventually persevere but
just suffice it to say there's there's a
lot of water